thomas bonjour alors ambiance très
gourdin vous êtes on imagine
parfaitement une atmosphère particulière
il absolument on n'est pas très loin de
l'entrée pour les familles c'est à dire
qu'on a vu depuis ce matin les familles
qui tarit qui arrivait au fur et à
mesure pour assister à cette cérémonie
beaucoup d'entre elles avaient notamment
des portraits de l'être cher qu'elles
ont perdu le jour des attentats du 11
septembre alors évidemment beaucoup
d'émotion il ya aussi beaucoup de
personnes qui sont simplement venus pour
assister à cette cérémonie a alors
assisté c'est un bien grand mot parce
qu'ils soient en fait et bien derrière
ce dispositif de sécurité dispositif
vécu de sécurité très importants autour
de ground zero et a donc beaucoup
d'américains qui ont décidé de venir
spécialement pour l'occasion des
américains qui viennent un peu des
quatre coins du pays et quand on leur
demande pourquoi c'est important pour
eux de venir aujourd'hui est bien parce
qu'ils veulent absolument que tout le
monde se rappelle ce qui est arrivé il y
a vingt ans jour pour jour il parle
beaucoup de la transmission notamment
pour la jeune génération parce que les
personnes qui sont en train d'entrer
dans l'âge adulte en ce moment on était
ban est forcément lors du 11 septembre
2001 et les américains avec lesquels
j'ai pu échanger nous explique que c'est
très important pour eux et bien que le
message continue d'être passé parce
qu'évidemment cela a été un choc immense
à l'époque les états unis frappaient en
plein coeur cela paraissait encore
inimaginables et bien ces attentats et
bien ils ont marqué beaucoup l'opinion
il ya aussi à des personnes qui sont
rassemblés ici avec des messages
politiques j'ai pu voir un homme
notamment avec une pancarte adressé à
joe biden où il fait référence aux
treize soldats qui sont morts en
afghanistan lors du retrait dans un
attentat lors du retrait des troupes
américaines d'afghanistan
et puis il ya aussi des vétérans j'ai pu
aussi croiser un vétéran de l'armée
américaine cette semaine qui me disait
qu'il était très énervé aussi par la
situation en afghanistan c'est un
contexte forcément un peu spéciale pour
joe biden d'ailleurs qui est arrivé vous
l'avais dit à la cérémonie entourée de
barack obama et 2000 clinton les trois
présidents démocrates il faut noter que
george w bush lui se rend au mémorial du
vol le 93 et que donald trump lui n'a
pas forcément pour le moment prévu
d'assister aux cérémonies il ya aussi
d'autres controverses autour de ces
attentats du 11 septembre c'est un
survivant que j'ai pu rencontrer cette
semaine qui est bien se bat depuis des
années pour que les documents autour des
enquêtes du 11 septembre soit enfin
déclassifiés par les agences de
renseignement et par les autorités je
propose de regardez ce reportage qu'on a
tourné cette semaine ici à new york
tim folique nommé qu rarement les pieds
à ground zero il y a vingt ans ce new
yorkais se trouvait au 80e étage de la
tour sud du world trade center la
deuxième à avoir été frappée par un
avion
contre les recommandations des autorités
ne suivant que son instinct team se rend
d'abord aux étages supérieurs pour
inviter ses collègues à évacuer les
lieux certains refusant team lui décide
de descendre les étages il ne le sait
pas encore mais cette décision va lui
sauver la vie
l'impact de l'avion a eu lieu je crois
entre le 82e et le 84e étage de la tour
le service des ressources humaines de la
banque où je travaillais se situer à ses
étages et mes amis et des employés ont
péri évidemment lorsque l'avion a frappé
ses étages
j'ai eu la chance de me trouver
plusieurs étages plus bas ce qui m'a
permis de m'en sortir
tim se sait chanceux il n'est sorti de
la tour que quelques secondes avant
qu'elles ne s'effondrent de ce jour
terrible il a gardé une blessure à la
jambe quelques photos mais surtout une
amertume celle de ne jamais avoir eu de
réponse à toutes ces questions c'est
pourquoi il se bat depuis des années
pour que les documents de l'enquète du
11 septembre soit enfin déclassifie
je crois que l'histoire complète du 11
septembre n'a pas encore été écrite on
ne sera pas capable d'écrire cette
histoire de ce qu'il s'est réellement
passé en tant que ces documents ne
seront pas sortis
il est plus que temps pour nous d'avoir
accès à ces documents ce qui nous
préoccupe le plus c'est de savoir qui
figurent dans ces documents on pense on
sait qu'il ya des agents saoudiens qui
apparaissent dans ces documents donc
dans un sens ce qu'il s'est passé ici
c'est qu'il ya des gens au sein de notre
gouvernement qui protège les saoudiens
je ne sais pas pourquoi mais ça ne
devrait pas être le cas
alors tim que vous avez entendu dans ce
reportage il a signé une lettre au début
du mois d'août avec 1800 autre personne
que ce soit des survivants ou des
familles de victimes du 11 septembre
l'aide qui était adressé à joe biden lui
demandant là encore de faire la
transparence sur ces documents on lui
demandant même de ne pas se rendre aux
cérémonies tant que ce ne serait pas
fait alors joe biden il faut le savoir a
signé un décret il y a maintenant
quelques jours pour justement permettre
la déclassification d'un certain nombre
de documents mais elle les survivants et
notamment team avec qui j'ai pu échanger
maintenant les attendait évidemment des
actes parce que des promesses ils ont
ont déjà eu dans le passé sans que cela
n'ait jamais abouti thomas merci
beaucoup pour tout ces précisions